hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start
warning spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain a 2021 american
action and thriller movie called red
notice
make sure to watch it till the end
because there will be a huge twist
the movie begins with a tale about
cleopatra and marc anthony on their
wedding day he presented her with three
bejeweled eggs as a symbol of his
undying devotion
since then the eggs were believed to be
mere myths for centuries but in 1907 a
local farmer in cairo unearthed two of
them however the third egg was never
found
in the present day special agent john
hartley a criminal profiler for the fbi
and an interpol agent does arrive at a
museum in rome after being given
information by its reliable source
called the bishop that one of the eggs
stored in the museum is going to be
stolen
upon arrival at the display room the egg
is still in the position and intact
hardly scans the 18-karat gold egg with
a thermal sensor and discovers that it
is not reflecting the heat in the room
meaning that it is a fake egg
to prove his theory he grabs a coke from
a visitor and pours it into the egg as
daz orders the guard to seal the room
immediately international art thief
nolan booth reveals himself and manages
to escape from the room the guards go
after him but he is able to eliminate
all of them by disintegrating the
scaffolding causing it to collapse while
he manages to reach the upper floor of
the room however harley comes in and
corners booth they engage in a fight
causing both of them to fall out of a
window booth manages to slide down
through a pipe and run away with a
stolen motorcycle
hardly attempts to chase him with a
super cool sports car but he is a bad
driver and immediately gets deboned by a
gelato truck
56 hours after the heist booth arrives
at his hideout in bali with the egg in
his possession however hartley has been
waiting for him and brings out interpol
agents to arrest him and secure the egg
hartley reveals that the bishop sells
booth out and leaks the hideout's
location to the fbi agent as harley puts
the egg in the truck the bishop who
disguises herself as one of the team
members switches out the real egg for a
fake one
the next day harley who plans to leave
rome in an hour is confronted by das she
shows him the fake egg and drops it to
the floor accusing hartley for swapping
the egg she also notes that a swiss bank
account in hartley's name has just
received an 8 million wire transfer
despite hardly begging and keeps saying
that he is innocent he is arrested and
is sent to a russian prison
things get worse when hardly finds out
that booth is his cellmate while eating
both of them think that hartley was set
up by the bishop hartley states that she
has successfully taken out her lead
competitor booth and lead investigator
himself in one move or two birds one egg
the renowned art thief reveals the
bishop's plan to gather all cleopatra's
egg and sell them to an egyptian
billionaire for 300 million dollars by
the night of his daughter's wedding
they also know that the second egg is
currently owned by an international arms
dealer sotofoche and is locked away in a
secret fault inside his house the only
way to steal it is by sneaking into the
fault during one of his annual parties a
few moments later booth deliberately
yells out to the whole cafeteria that
hardly is not a cop and or feels that he
is an fbi agent as we know because the
prisoners hate cops and they are not
that dumb one of them drago grande
approaches them and challenges hardly
although he tells him that he doesn't
want trouble drago launches a punch
causing the guards to react and bring
them back to the cell not long after
hartley and booth are brought to the
bishop who claims herself as the captain
of the prison
she reveals that she is the one who
swapped the egg and sent the money to an
account registered in hartley's name she
informs him that she is going to steal
the second egg in less than 48 hours and
tells hartley that booth knows the
location of the final egg
she offers to give him 10 percent of the
money and will let him out if he reveals
the egg's location but he refuses to
tell anything they decide to team up and
start planning their escape plan before
sleeping we discover that booth is the
son of a swiss police captain and he
states that his father was a jerk who
accused him of stealing his watch even
though he didn't his dad refused to talk
to him for a year until he discovered
that it was hidden behind some paperwork
the next day they execute their escape
plan
first booth throws nitroglycerin into a
machine causing it to explode in the
ensuing chaos they managed to escape
from the building by using a key card
that booth stole from the security guard
when drago attacked hartley booth
eventually makes it into the helicopter
while hardly is distracting the guards
hardly attempts to run towards the
chopper but a guard fires a missile at
him causing the bridge to collapse
luckily just before booth starts flying
away he manages to climb up and jump
into the helicopter
however the guard attempts to fire a
missile again but hardly manages to open
the other door causing it to fly through
the chopper and hit a mountain instead
in london the bishop is keeping an agent
captive in his office while using his
computer to send a message to daz
informing her that hartley and booth has
escaped from the prison she also sends
an invitation to soto forte's party
in the other side booth calls his friend
tomboy to pick him and harley up and
take them on a plane to soto forte's
house while hartley is studying about
the house master plan booth shares his
plan to get into forties safe which is
located upstairs and heavily guarded by
using a hidden entrance
in addition the whole activities in the
house are monitored by cctvs which are
already using the latest technology he
also adds that the only way to get
through the full door is with facial and
voice recognition which booth is
prepared for with his own face and voice
replacement technology last but not
least they also need to enter a 12-digit
passcode which can only be found in soto
fortu's phone and needs a fingerprint
authentication long story short they
arrive at the party which is a
masquerade party hartley meets bishop
and asks her for a dance which is not
part of the plan soto fortu spots hardly
dancing with the most beautiful girl at
the party which makes him jealous he
politely asks her to dance with him on
the other side booth collects his
fingerprints and hardly manages to steal
the bone
both of them then proceed to the fall
room booth hacks the cctv and they
manage to reach the vault they
accidentally break the glass that
contains focus fingerprint but luckily
they still can find the fingerprint and
proceed to unlock the door
just before they get in daz comes in
pointing her gun at them she orders
hartley to arrest booth to prove his
innocence he refuses to do so and gets
into the vault with booth
unfortunately bishop has somehow already
made her way inside and fights them for
the egg
after a long fight she manages to
outskill both of them while sotofoche
and his men come into the vault
bishop surprisingly has planned this
with him informing him that hartley and
booth would come for the egg
they are then knocked out by fortu's men
bishop forces booth to tell them the
location of the third egg or hartley
will be shocked with electric cables
he still refuses to talk even after
bishop has increased the voltage to
maximum
running out of patience voces strangles
hardly and he finally leaks the location
of the last egg which is in a pyramid in
cairo
just before the bear leave bishop
poisons soto forge's drink causing him
to collapse
as the woman leaves voce awakens but has
his vision impaired and he starts firing
wildly at hartley and booth
thanks to forte the bullet hits the cuff
and hardly manages to free himself and
run away with booth
they managed to escape from the
underground only to find himself in the
middle of bullfighting long story short
the man make it onto a train where booth
admits that he lied about the last egg's
location however he is unwilling to tell
hartley either hartley nearly throws him
off the train until he relents and pulls
him back in turns out that hartley's
father was a con man and he is a cop
while boo's dad was a cop and he is now
a thief
because of that similarity they decide
to help each other booth then reveals
that the third egg was hidden by rudolph
zike
hitler's personal antiquities dealer and
was sent to argentina along with all
stolen nazi artifacts
he eventually found out that the watch
that his father loved so much was
actually containing the coordinates to
the bunker where the egg was kept
they arrive at the exact location of the
bunker which is in the middle of the
forest
however booth realizes that all this
time he reads the map upside down which
makes hardly furious when he smashes the
compass they realize that they are
currently standing above it and starts
digging where they find a passageway and
a huge fault containing loads of stolen
artifacts
after exploring the vault they finally
find the final egg but suddenly bishop
arrives along with daz and her team who
have been following bishop they attempt
to escape by using an old mercedes car
while being chased by the interpol
agents the thieves managed to eliminate
the interpol agent's car leaving das
alone
the three then ride their car out of the
cave and free fall over a waterfall
booth secures the egg and escapes from
the water but is unable to find hardly
he drops the egg and attempts to go back
into the water to save him but he turns
out to be fine
hartley discovers that booth actually
cares for him not long after bishop
survives the accident and when it looks
like harley is about to arrest her they
kiss instead
it turns out that harley has been
working with bishop the whole time
they are a couple who have been planning
the egg heists from the beginning and
use booth to lead them to the third egg
she also reveals that the electrocution
scene was intended to pass the cuff's
key booth is forced to hand the egg over
and they leave him cuffed to a tree
the couple traveled to cairo where the
billionaire is conducting his daughter's
wedding
he presents three cleopatra's eggs to
the bride as the wedding gift out of
nowhere ed sheeran also presents at the
party and gives a special musical
performance
suddenly das and interpol agents come in
and arrest a billionaire eddie is also
arrested because he attempts to fight
the guards
the interpol agent secured the egg while
hardly and bishop gets away unnoticed
with 300 million dollars in their bank
account at the end of the movie the
couple are on a boating holiday when
they are approached by booth he was
being caught by dust but managed to
escape
he informs him that he tipped off dust
about their bank account where the 300
million dollars was transferred and she
froze all the money he then offers them
to work together on another heist or he
will leave them to be arrested because
the interpol agents are on their way
towards the yacht
the couple reluctantly agree and they
flee
das returns to the office and issues a
red notice on all three thieves
on the other side they arrive in paris
and are ready to execute their next
heist the louvre
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching